hi I'm Eric Boston and the ashes and
then the snow dust of the Battle of
Winterfell the next on Game of Thrones
trailer for season 8 episode 4 gives us
just enough clues to give us an idea of
what might come next in this last war
for a chair and the insane ways to show
could further twist the Valyrian steel
knife and our shattered expectations I'm
gonna break down the details that you
might have overlooked and spoiler
indicates into my predictions that I've
been writing they were in your life for
if they don't end up being right in that
ruins eco life too let's get started
[Music]
we have won the great war now we will
win the last war the teaser opens with
plumes of smoke and flame outside the
walls of Winterfell later in this teaser
there's a shot of what this is bodies of
the Dead stacked up with Daenerys Sam
grey worm Sansa Jon and torment carrying
torches toward this pile and what looks
like some kind of ceremonial funeral
pyre after the battle this would be the
second funeral pyre that Danny would
have to use to burn a loved one after
her season one goodbye to Khal Drogo
traditionally the northerners burn their
dead to prevent the risk of them coming
back as whites but now that the night
king is gonzo does burning these bodies
serve a practical purpose or just a
ritualistic one I suppose it would be a
lot of graves to dig and the permafrost
in that ground must be pretty sturdy
perhaps they're still feeling
superstitious that the night king will
return or that he's not really dead
since there was only one witness a fern
perhaps the way the previous three-eyed
raven passed on his title to bran right
before he passed the night king could
have passed on his leadership of the
White Walkers to another figure at the
moment of his death and somewhere up
north there's a little blue baby
crawling his way south so the
northerners so like we gotta burn
everything just to be safe I know I know
this sounds like the kind of crazy
crackpot tin foil stuff that those old
grouchy northerners would probably say
to each other while they're burning
their dead beloved family cat in front
of their kids their zombie babies come
and burn it all now I can't tell if that
torchbearer behind Sansa is Arya or
someone else maybe it's a Lascar stark I
just say that because it wouldn't make
sense for Arya to skip this ceremony she
didn't stand with a family to greet Jon
and Daenerys in the first episode of the
season because she prefers to be a face
in the crowd
scope out the situation before she
reveals herself and she just proved that
she is way more effective in general
when she stays in the shadows the
direwolf ghost is also visible meaning
he survived what was the dumbest
Dothraki cavalry charge ever thank the
gods there's also a shot of Cersei
Lannister apparently the last villain
standing on this series overlooking her
new golden company in King's Landing the
golden company is led by captain
Strickland and they're composed of
18,000 infantry 2,000 cavalry which
didn't seem like much before especially
without the damn war elephants they were
supposed to have
I'll keep asking till I get it but now
that Danny's army has whittled down to
some rattled unsullied and a couple of
hole filled dragons it might be more of
an even fight
you're on Greyjoy joint Cersei as she
wears this new Lannister red wardrobe
before she were black as the color of
mourning for Tommen but now she's back
in her Lannister family colors to
identify herself apart from merely being
a successor to someone else is
interesting how Cersei and Daenerys are
seen in the color red this episode red
in crimson both are in the color scheme
for both a Lannister and Targaryen
sigils but it sets them up as dual
figures with the same goal both of whom
are willing to bleed into their clothes
to get it it's like two women who hate
each other showing up to a party wearing
the same color it's awkward Daenerys
declares that they've won the Great War
but now they'll have to win the last war
which cuts to a shot of Dany toasting
the northerners is a cheer and victory
but there may be something screwy going
on with the editing here Dani is wearing
different clothes in these two shots and
they're clearly part of different scenes
I'm thinking that Dany brought up this
now onto the last wall lying to a
smaller room less enthusiastic one with
like John or Davos saying shouldn't my
queen I'm with you but I don't know if
you'll convince the other northerners to
help you take the Iron Throne but you
know nothing to stop any of them
bringing it up to them and then the big
room victory toast
Daenerys get some pictures initially but
then she starts chanting one more war
one more war and then you know it gets
awkwardly quiet and just to break the
tension tormund Giantsbane slurps from
that horde of milk we'll see let's move
on to the second half
rip her out root and stem Daenerys
greets drogon and the surrounding
terrain looks significantly less
snow-covered than what we saw before
there's always that theory that the
White Walkers brought the season of
winter with them and that without them
winter doesn't really exist now I don't
know if all of the seasons of Westeros
are just magic it did still seem to be
snowing after Arya killed the night king
maybe the White Walkers just have the
power of storm from x-men but there
definitely is some connection between
the White Walkers and how cold it is
there's a quick shot of arias smooch and
Gendry and this might be the only
victory lapping aria does again she does
not want to be in the spotlight I could
see her allowing John or Daenerys to
take credit for the night King's death
since really it was only branch who was
there to see it and publicly John and
Danny's plan was for one of them were
their dragons to kill the night king so
claiming that victory would help further
either of their positions politically
another shot shows Dany marching away
sternly brats reacted in the northerners
feeling less eager to join her march
south one of those northerners staying
put is Sansa who watches Danny's army
marched away from Winterfell remember
there must always be a stark in
Winterfell
the white Walker war being over now
forces John and the rest to address that
complicated political question that he
had been avoiding the confusions of the
late Ned umber who is your grace
who is my lady his very Secretary of
Agriculture now and will John keeps
secret his true lineage and support
Danny or undercut Dany and pursue his
own claim to the Iron Throne or will he
suggests that the to marry and be Cole
monarchs and maybe not yeah I'm sure
like Benioff tells Weis that they're
co-creators to Sansa seas Daenerys is to
surviving dragons flying off and notice
now wriggles wings look damaged holes in
his wings might make it really hard for
him to fly straight and accurately make
him less of a fearsome weapon if they
were to try to attack King's Landing
regal also soars over the Targaryen
fleet I don't know just given those
ominous shot from the opening credit to
this season showing the Scorpion weapon
aimed at the dragon skulls in the red
keep I'm feeling worried about how well
Danny's dragons are gonna hold up your
on drops down to a knee before Cersei
maybe he's proposing marriage though I'm
curious to see the blowback that you're
on will face for losing Yara Greyjoy his
prized prisoner as well as a few ships
of his fleet to the Iron Islands if Yara
is back there now claiming to be Queen
his rule and status as a
in his own eyes are now in question the
final shot of the teaser shows Cersei
looking pretty smug flanked by urine in
the mountain and Daenerys is voiceover
declares rip pat out treating stem root
and stem is an interesting phrase that's
been used a few times before last season
arya spoke it when she was posing as
Walder Frey taunting the phrase that she
killed them that they shouldn't have
left one wolf alive after the red
wedding and back in the first book
maester pycelle supported Robert's
desire to assassinate Danny saying
treason is a noxious weed it must be
torn up root and stem and seed losing
dr. Seuss
so Cersei and her late husband's failure
to eradicate the entire Targaryen
bloodline root and stem is now coming
back to her in a possible day of
reckoning but you know it also suggests
that Daenerys is scorched earth dreams
might be wishful thinking like think
about it root and stem it's literal
overkill you can't erase someone from
this earth that was the night Kings goal
and he failed spectacularly so while I
would be surprised if Cersei Lannister
survives a series the seeds of her
treachery will take root and you could
say they already have do you think the
night king could return or is Cersei the
more interesting villain anyway comment
down below with your thoughts it
subscribe blue rock stars on YouTube and
subscribe to our Game of Thrones podcast
Westeros weekly wherever you get your
podcasts follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at UK boss I'll see you guys
after I finally take a stress nap god I
hope they don't do anything to go strong
[Music]